so after years and years of buildup all
the hype has finally come to this
The Avengers there has never been a
movie quite like this done before six
previous film starring individual
superheroes that were all coming
together for one event that was planned
from the very beginning though you could
look at them as individual stories they
were all leading up to one grand event
this was the event now don't get me
wrong there have been crossovers before
but nothing like this and nothing this
well thought-out so there was a little
bit of a concern would it pay off this
would definitely have a good opening
weekend no matter what it's been build
up so much but would it be the gigantic
hit everybody wanted would it be as good
as the other Marvel movies or as
promised even better
ten times better something spectacular
huge well the short answer is yes not
only was this film a mega mega mega mega
hit but both critics and audiences alike
agree it was a ton of fun and worth the
wait the movie centers around the return
of the sinister Loki he apparently is in
cahoots with an evil force in space who
wants to what else take over the world
of course he plans to do so using a
magic scepter to hypnotize people and a
gigantic alien army to open up a
dimension and bring him into our world
and slaving mankind who can stop them
The Avengers of course most of them just
having come off hit movies Iron Man
Captain America Thor and even the Hulk
played this time by Mark Ruffalo but
also included our characters we haven't
seen that much of like Black Widow and
Hawkeye and the film literally from this
point on is nothing but one-liners and
action and I know it sounds strange but
it's actually kind of perfect when you
see these characters together a lot of
them with big personalities just having
come off of big movies what do you want
to see you want to see them interact
that includes working off of each other
talking to each other getting in fights
throwing insults and because these
actors and characters are so strong and
so defined it really works the whole
movie could be all of them just stuck in
a room shooting the and you know
what it'd be okay
they're that interesting and that much
fun to watch but of course that's not
what people are paying to see they're
paying to see action and when the action
gets going it's some of the most fun
I've seen an audience have in a movie
theater every superhero has a unique way
of fighting a villain and each one has a
different personality trait to make it
interesting well for the most part we
don't really know Hawkeye yet but yeah
we're not Avengers to a given time a lot
of these movies as I mentioned before
deliver a lot of character but sometimes
skimp a little bit on the action
particularly in the climax the great
thing about this movie is that it makes
you think it's about to end they do the
big team shot you think all right well
they're just gonna punch out a few more
and then we're gonna stop but nope it's
just beginning they spend a lot of time
fighting creatures in the city and
unlike transformers you don't get tired
of it it gives you the exact amount you
want to see every superhero does what
you want to see the superheroes do The
Hulk jumps around and smashes things he
punches this giant whale I don't know
what is Captain America's throwing his
shield Iron Man flying around shooting
stuff even Black Widow who we didn't see
that much before this movie suddenly
becomes this really cool character she
actually might be my favorite out of all
of them and yeah I'm waiting for that
damn movie to the one element of the
film that is kind of lazy is the story
but to its credit story is not what you
want to focus on here this is the first
time you've seen all these characters
come together and you just want to see
them be those characters and beat
up so the story is very minimal hell it
doesn't even really make that much sense
Loki wants to get all the Avengers
together knowing they won't get a log
and that would somehow destroy them okay
well as Tony Stark himself said not a
great plan the whole story is kind of
like that there's all these weird little
conveniences that don't really add up
and are kind of confusing but really you
don't care you're there to see The
Avengers fly around and be the Avengers
and this movie gives you that in bucket
loads they have been hyping this thing
up forever one of the biggest Marvel
teams of all time actually comes to the
big screen and it delivers does
that much drama no is there that much
thinking in it absolutely not but it's
just an incredibly fun dumb summer film
this is the kind of movie you want to
see kind of mindless you want to see a
lot of dumb explosions but it's done
with so much wit and humor that you find
yourself enjoying even the silliest
moments it's nice to see a cinematic
gamble like this payoff and for the
right reasons if we just started off
with this movie before Iron Man Captain
America and all the other films it
wouldn't be as good it'd be impressive
but it'd just be too jumbled because you
wouldn't have all the characters defined
well now that we do know all these
characters and we enjoy them and they
certainly proven themselves to be
entertaining they come together
beautifully I even kind of find myself
enjoying Mark Ruffalo as the Hulk I'll
admit I like it word Norton just a
little bit more because I think he's
such an engaging actor but I like the
take he does he plays it as a guy who's
been spending years trying to achieve in
her call so he kind of looks half awake
sometime but it's actually intentional
it doesn't seem lazy at all it seems
like a guy who's just trying to keep his
rage under control because he knows
what'll happen with it and so he
sacrifices some of his stronger emotions
to keep everything balanced it would
have been cool to see Norton but this
guy's a good replacement what else can I
say it's the Avengers one of the
highest-grossing films of all time one
of the most hyped up films of all time
and it gave you exactly what you wanted
it's silly it's funny it's over-the-top
it's a comic book movie that no part in
it can you say it's not a comic book
movie it just drenches itself in it and
after years and years these were seen as
embarrassing films to make now they
completely won us over and everybody is
trying to do exactly what the Avengers
did create a movie universe something
that can continue and all these other
characters can interact with each other
and come in at different ideas they can
all try it and some even succeed but
none of us will forget who did it first
why because it was just so damn fun
you